I am here to be a voice for the
voiceless okay I can't tell you how
proud I was to see you out on the front
lines you know in the protest with
everybody really trying to use your
voice for a change I mean what compelled
you to say I need to get up out of my
house and go down and participate you
know I have definitely been a witness to
a lot of police brutality in my lifetime
and when I watched the video when George
Floyd was murdered it really touched me
in a different way for me to sit there
and see a black man who was completely
unarmed not resisting laying on the
ground face on the pavement a knee and
his neck two other officers laying on
the applying pressure on the rest of his
body the amount of time that he was down
the every cry that he cried out when he
asked for his mother all of that touched
me in a completely different way I'm a
mother now and you know god forbid I
would have to go through anything like
that to lose a child god forbid if I'm
already gone my child is on the ground
under the knee of a police officer who
was supposed to protect and serve them
snuffing their life out with soulless
eyes so to be able to see that it felt
like I was literally spent it felt like
I was there it really did it didn't feel
like I was just looking at a video in my
phone it felt very personal to me
and it awoke something in me that I knew
was there I have always had a heart for
the people it's in my blood my
grandfather have represented Williams
and my father raised us in that way to
have a heart for the people charitable
I've marched with my grandfather in the
past but it ignited what was in me to
want to fight for real change and to
understand that I need to be with my
people with our allies side-by-side and
fighting for real change in justice for
George Florence family and for the other
families who have been victims of police
brutality forgive me if I get a little
emotional I you just described in that
video took me right back to seeing it
the first time you know and it breaks
you in a way that number one you don't
expect because you don't know him but
you connect with him I don't have to be
I don't have to know him personally I am
George Floyd I am African American my
brother is african-american his children
are african-american you know people I
work with you know we should not be
targeted because of the skin that we
live in and our skin became a negative
very long ago and we've been living in
this negativity in attack and being
attacked for a very long time and if I
can do anything if anything was in my
power to help lift the voice of the
protesters who are out there every day
tirelessly peacefully trying to be heard
be seen be felt if I can do anything to
assist with that how dare I sit at home
and not get out there and be active I
saw the video that you posted of the
beam tear gassed
[Music]
take me to that moment and what you were
thinking in that moment and what that
moment is like they've been very
peaceful protests but this one by far
was the most peaceful it was very
organized and we were very respectful at
the police and there was a moment where
we saw music was starting to be played
and people kind of decided to just enjoy
and be with and live within that moment
and so they were enjoying the music
Dennis turned to me and said hey you
should show this you know the media
showing so much negativity about the
protesters show this and I said okay and
I turned my phone on at the same time
right before I turned my phone on I look
and I saw a couple officers taking Annie
and I said oh my god they're going to
take Annie with us they're going to join
us we start and we were going to chant
join us within seconds all this is
happening at the same time I then see
the police officer
pull over his gas mantle so at that
point I'm like okay no they're not
joining us this is turning into
something else and it was it just more
than not being able to breathe because
of the gas more than my eyes being on
fire like I had never experienced before
more than having to feel like I was
literally running for my life in my own
state where I was peacefully protesting
and that's my right
I felt like we were being silenced and
you feel like you're being silenced and
your whole purpose is to be heard and
get your message across can be
devastating so you know yes I took some
gas and I ended to my eyes and I had to
have milk and water poured in my face
listen I'm all right I'm all right
and everyone else who's out there
fighting the good fight they will also
be alright but it has to be known that
it has to be demanded that we are able
to peacefully protest it is the voice of
the people this is this is how they are
being heard we have to be able to do
that now our curfew in Atlanta
o'clock this was around 7:45 so I really
didn't understand why that happened but
again the message that we have is not
going to die it's not George Floyd will
not have died in vain Brianna Taylor
will not have died in vain and the other
people who have been victims of Fuji
tality will not have died in vain we are
going to continue to fight and want
justice and want equal to feel equal to
our counterparts somebody may be
watching this at home and they may be
saying I hear you Portia and I I agree
with everything you saying but I'm
scared to go join the protest I'm scared
to step outside and do this what's your
message to somebody who might be on the
bubble who is with you but but it's just
afraid to take that step you should be
more fearful to stay home you should be
more careful to not think that if we
don't use our voice whomever you are you
stand to leave your family members your
younger family members a country that
will kill them this is life or death so
you know take that fear fill it
acknowledge it because I believe in that
no we are all human villains fear is
natural crying as natural as you're
doing during this interview all of those
things are very natural and real but to
have real change we have to activate and
have practical ways to make it happen
and in the real world that is getting
out there and protesting and joining
others who are like you and like-minded
and want to have changed and also going
to go vote I saw that Andy posted when
you were out protesting preach Portia he
was very happy for you and proud of you
how was your Bravo family supported you
and your other cast mates supported you
you know in this in this fight as well
you know it was very heartwarming for
Andy to reach out to me and to know that
he stands beside me as my boss and me
being african-american and him knowing
what we're going through as the people
it was very very important and powerful
for him to repost that and give it
attention and and show that he's on the
right side of history with this one
and I'm as far as my castmates some of
them have reached out candy has even
offered to give money towards helping
bill all other people out I don't want
to name people because I don't want
anybody to feel left out they're not
about any of that
but you know of course my main people
need me you know take whatever they have
been very supportive house Kenya's
business I saw that she posted it did
get vandalized and she was you know
understandably very upset do they plan
to rebuild and plan to you know stay in
the area I'm not really sure what she's
gonna do but she's in good spirits
um you know she's she's doing fine that
I'm sure she has insurance and she will
deal with it she is focused on what I'm
focused on which is the issue and in
seeking justice I saw your your post
where you said if you need help if
you've been arrested DM Dennis because
we you know we we're here to help
um you know this is this for you and and
him as a family this is what you all
want to stand for in life and teach
Pilar yeah absolutely you know when you
pray for a purpose in your relationship
which is what I had been praying for
during this quarantine you don't know
what God is going to lay behind you and
this has been something that you know he
is very passionate about and so am I um
the email for people to contact if
they've been arrested while peacefully
protesting is help us at new civil
rights org and someone will contact you
we have attorneys on standby to help get
people out we also have money our
personal money we have people who have
asked to also pay for other people to
get out and that is what we want to do
because again we cannot a fringe on
people's right to be able to peacefully
protest not anybody was doing anything
other than that but if you were we are
here to help you and make sure you can
get right back out there cuz guess what
you get up and you wipe yourself off and
you continue to fight the good fight
what you learned about yourself I
haven't learned much about myself
because I knew that I always would fight
for mine okay you know I I'm a
first-time mother and I'm very
protective over my daughter I'm very
protective over anyone who was
to me period and you know when you talk
about the fact that right now everybody
is protesting for humanity just to
simply treat just for just for George
Floyd's who have simply be treated like
a human and not be on the ground or you
know poseable is what we are fighting
for so I am fighting for humanity those
much human brothers and sisters and when
you're out there in the field you
actually see that our allies of every
different races etc backgrounds cultures
they feel the same way I do
and we are out there with the exact same
passion as if George Floyd was our
brother and you know if you don't see
yourself in what is happening in America
then you are a part of the problem
of course sure what do you think your
granddaddy would think of the climate
that we're in right now I really think
that I really think that he would be
more focused on what are we gonna do
what are you gonna do how is America
gonna react because he and anyone else
who fought for us in civil rights is
gonna feel like we laid this out for you
guys you saw us be arrested you saw a
famous treatise saw dogs bite us you saw
us be shot you saw us be hung you saw us
not be able to vote you saw all of that
and I really feel like our ancestors my
grandfather is what would want us to
have seen that and to continue the fight
I would really do believe that your your
spirit is so strong but how is your
heart right now this is not anything
that I think I even expected to be in
the middle of while fighting a pandemic
you know and I just feel like it is just
so ironic that we were just
concentrating on fighting for our lives
and staying in our homes to protect
ourselves and Here I am and the rest of
America is coming out of our homes to
again fight for our lives because this
is life or death at this moment if
we lose this battle there are more
african-americans who are going to die
and one of them could be in my family
one of them could be in yours what it
can be just that close to us and so it's
just my heart is heavy but I just try to
reach channel that energy and that's the
same thing I try to do what I'm out
amongst the people protesting when I'm
online protesting etc and lifting my
voice is to help us channel that energy
channel that passion channel that anger
child that pain that we feel and today
is a good day to do that is to go boat
you can go over early here in Atlanta a
lot of other places you can go float
take all of that get your butt in the
car and go to those polls and vote
because that'll be the first step for
real change there's been a lot of
attention paid to some of the other
Bravo stars not necessarily from Atlanta
at all that may not have spoken out or
spoken out in ways trying to find a kind
word for this I don't even know if there
is well actually there really isn't one
really stupid ignorant comments what's
your what's your message to to some of
those folks to be honest with you I
haven't seen any of that I you know I'm
very focused and I just don't have any
time for you know the rhetoric that the
president is speaking about or if any
other person is saying anything that
that's negative and distracting to what
I'm focused on I'm focused on justice
for George Floyd okay I I just believed
that his family is hurting right now and
I want what his family wants and that's
justice I want what any of the other
family who have recently lost someone
with in 2022 early release police
brutality
I want what they want in this justice
and that's all I'm focused on I I don't
even know about what anybody else is
doing if it's not like minded with the
mission at hand amen
I hear you
you